chris cuomo is now doing a total about
face he's saying he
he never supported blm violence what
does it
good is it to have a mouth that says
blue lives matter
if you're gonna have hands and feet that
do this
around 140 officers assaulted some very
badly
this is the truth period
it is no less the truth because black
lives matter supporters
committed acts of violence too
even if you want to believe that the
media was okay with what they did
which sure as hell isn't true on this
show but even if you want to say
they were it doesn't change this
and be clear what happened on january
6th
has no equal in terms of
what and who was targeted
and how and you know it
sure as hell didn't happen on this there
no one defended black lives matter on
this show and all the violence that they
engaged with
right right roll the tape now too many
see the protests
as the problem no the problem is what
forced
your fellow citizens to take to the
streets persistent
and poisonous inequities and injustice
and please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful please show us so chris
cuomo himself was defending
violent blm riots now he's realizing uh
gosh that doesn't that's not playing
very well
and we i want to accuse the right of
being violent so yeah okay we're going
to pull that back
they're realizing that the extremes are
very tough here they're realizing that
people are
asserting their political rights again
continue to assert those political
rights that's a good thing these these
eggheads these technic rats these
liberal establishmentarians don't want
you to do it which should make us
readier all the more hey there i'm glad
you like that clip you can get the whole
episode called getting over
self-government here
you don't even look if you ring the bell
and subscribe you'll get the
notifications you won't need me to tell
you
things like this you can go get that
episode you can also get it on apple
podcasts everywhere else you get your
your podcasts you can also get my book
the
number one national best-selling
speechless
sold many many more copies than the
number one bestseller on the new york
times list but we're very proud to be
snubbed by the new york times thank you
very much to everyone who's read it
thanks for leaving a review we'll see
you next time